oh my goodness
all right Mama how do you feel this is
tight so um it felt like it was a long
time coming yeah and then once it came
it like arrived really really freaking
fast what I mean by that is there's a
lot of planning that goes on first of
all you have to find the right guy right
like you have to like kind of shop
around see who can one execute Your
Design uh if you want to get creative
with it and then two make sure that it
fits within your budget so we had like
interviewed a handful of people yeah if
you don't remember those Vlogs check it
out because that's when we made a really
stupid joke and then we showed on camera
how stupid we are it felt like those
Vlogs were like six months ago for real
it really I think we've been here for
three months it was probably six months
ago maybe not yeah we were uh yeah we
were in that apartment meeting with them
already and we haven't moved in yet
I don't even know all right
um so then uh they do we do the
blueprint the back and forth or we
select the person then at that point
there's a bunch of like design meetings
they really try to like capture you know
whatever creative thing you want in your
backyard
then that after the back and forth of
like the design then the negotiations
happen with all of like the the
trimmings and the finishes and the the
tiles and the lighting and the plants
there's a [__] oh [__] that goes into
this so that could be like a two three
month process in and of itself yeah then
it's quiet because now the permitting
has to take place and right now at least
in Nevada no it did take months it took
like two three months okay maybe not two
three months but it definitely took
months look at how cool that is that is
smart that is so cool you don't have to
bring [__] yeah just bring all the tools
in that thing so then
um we get it so then we're we're turning
in the application just to make sure if
we get approved for the design with the
HOA and the city right because the city
is like hey well we want to conserve
water so because of that they put in
this new law where like pools can't be
bigger than I forgot what the size is
yeah we have to follow that so there's
so many rules and laws and stuff that we
have to do with the city and also uh
with the HOA which is the community
so then that takes about a month or so
we don't know if we're gonna approved
declined lucky for us we got approved
once the approval happens now we have to
wait we're in a queue of like when the
excavators and all the plant all the all
the workers can come in and literally I
got it this week they're like hey
they're gonna show up in three days
seven a.m they might start excavation
today is the day 7 A.M I was like yeah
he's gonna start too they're like oh
we're definitely starting today and boom
here we are after waiting for so long
and then it just happens really fast raw
dog style here we are this was this is
right now it's 9 9 12 okay they came in
at seven this is already done so this is
what our pool's gonna look like this is
a size how do you feel I feel like I'm
just going
I feel extremely happy very similar to
you where it's like damn it just feels
like it's been a long time coming and
even taika's like when are we gonna have
a pool are we gonna have a pool and all
of our friends like are you guys can do
any of the backyard and we're always
like buy July by July and then you know
clock starts ticking it's like November
December January don't know if it's
gonna happen by July but guess what
they're here and the first step is to
draw where the pool's gonna be so they
spray paint and everything just to make
sure everything looks good and so yeah
we have a very unique shaped pool
as you guys have seen uh from all like
the designs and stuff so it's enough to
have people like Splash around and swim
there and also still have a lap pool
there's going to be all this Greenery
here a couple of fruit trees over here
like a play Space yes I wanted to I
wanted the backyard to feel like it has
an actual function yeah yeah and we want
it we're like taika and all those little
homies that he has now you can come over
and play and just hang out and have a
good ass time we wanted a very Zen but
you know like some like backyards It
Feels So Zen and so visually aesthetic
you're like oh I can't step here can't
step here it doesn't look playful we
wanted a very inviting one so
here it is
March April May June so we're four
months out at this point should be done
by the summer no turning back there's
Noah turning back
I'm not looking forward to it because if
you know Vegas it gets [__] hot so
I'm not looking forward to it yes
dipping in it every day for sure we're
gonna look so tan ooh see you later
vampire apparel [__] Twilight skin am
i absolute favorite part is this okay
it's the combination of everything so we
got
the pool right here right where it's
going to be you have the water
we got our we got our hangout spot right
here under the awning where we're not
getting fried in the Sun but look at
that view
the beautiful mountain view
we're gonna have the pool and that whole
entire wall is gonna be covered with
plants it's gonna look really green
it's going to be beautiful really really
excited
but first we got to pick up all of Mia's
dog [__]
uh yeah we gotta pick it up
good job Mama
so Ace our Builder is so nice he knows
that these things take a long long time
so he brought us this little like canvas
photograph he's like hey
it's sooner than you think you know
there's gonna be stressors where like
you build something and then the
permitting comes and you gotta wait so
there's gonna be a lot of like stop go
stop go stop go so he was like during
those times just look it's gonna be all
worth it
that's what it's gonna look like right
there
what do you think Mia did you think
you're gonna be adopted into such a cool
house the pool
are you going in circles
me do you know how to swim do you know
how to swim young lady are you gonna
swim with taika
are you so much paper
it's cool because although there's all
that excitement outside like just like a
team of like eight people just going ham
they're either like breaking down walls
picking up plants so they don't run them
over spray painting or like pounding
Nails into the ground
I'm watching all that happen I'm like
but it's still a normal work day so I
gotta get to work Mia is like what is
going on I want to be a guard dog but
these guys look friendly
so over here on this side
we still got to go to work some odd
brazody I think in her
and her meeting space in her office
right there just meeting with brie
so
time to go to work
I'll check back with you guys in a
little bit to see what other progress
they've done
by the way we recently found this Thai
market and I have all these new snacks
that I've been dying to try so there's
this one called it's funny well you see
the tie words there but it's called Euro
cake
and uh this is only look
a hundred calories
still on a diet still trying to have fun
and I was like what I have to get that
and uh what else did we get oh and I
found these protein noodles they're not
even protein noodles they're just Asian
noodles but the protein content is crazy
high and it's fat like the fettuccine
look how fat these guys are you see that
look at that 15 grams of protein with
only one gram of fat get out of here
isn't that crazy
and the thing that I'm about to try
right now that I'm super
duper excited for
is um I found
this Thai coffee right here instant
coffee
it's only 130 calories
and I actually drink this yesterday this
is a Thai tea so it's not like the Thai
tea with the creamer and the milk and
all already I just like how fragrant and
aromatic the Thai tea is and boy is that
being orange you know how like when you
get Thai tea it's like crazy orange it
came out exactly like that so super
excited I'm gonna try this
Thai copy before I get to work
by the way if you guys don't have one of
these Asian water heater things
you are living life wrong okay you need
to get one of these things because
anytime you need hot coffee or tea you
don't have to boil it's always piping
hot at 208 degrees
all the time oh that coffee smells good
I'm just stirring it
moment of truth it's really hot
it's good kind of reminds me like a
Vietnamese coffee but not as strong I
would say it's like a cross between like
a regular Mia get off the couch
a cross between like regular like uh
latte and then the stronger than that
but weaker than a Vietnamese coffee very
good
and you know I can't just eat that
coffee by itself
as a child of these guys
whoa look how soft it is
holy moly
hmm
this is good
what a Grizzle snap
200 calories for this little cake
it's coffee
I'll make it from my brush doesn't have
a good ass time damn
this is good
um
all right mid working I hear bathroom
amazing shield from the bathroom shout
out oh my God they're digging and I'm
looking and I'm like holy [__] they are
digging all right that is a beefy beefy
monster
dang
there is no turning back now that is
straight up hole in the ground
man at this rate they're gonna finish in
like a week
holy are you ready are you just ready to
swim young lady
yeah you're happy you look like a happy
happy girl happy happy
CUNY holy [__] this day cannot get
nuttier
it is straight up snowing out of nowhere
what
what look at this there is a pile up
whoa no wonder it was so cold earlier
there is a pile up of snow right there
you see that
so cool
what
we are literally getting our pool built
when it's snowing it does not get any
more appropriate than that because we
don't need the pool
hey Mia it's your favorite environment
it's this new
this is freaking
crazy dude shout outs to these workers
dude they don't give a [__] they just
keep going
but look at this
look at that look
four guys look at all you see all that
built up it just started so you can
still see a buildup of white
dude it's gonna be so cool this whole
place has just like a nice little one
inch layer of snow that is gonna be
awesome
bro this is so freaking rad
like it's straight up
snow down here look at the ground
straight up pile up of snow
this is so cool
it's been snowing
so much
to the point that everyone had to leave
because uh
I don't know if anyone was prepared for
because it looked like everyone just had
like hoodies and flannels and stuff
right
here it was snowing so hard
they actually cleared up right now and I
think
but look at that that whole mountain is
still covered in snow you see that
yes everyone left
progress
which is
a big old hole down there
it was very very cool
the Jiu Jitsu dummy I thought someone
was saying that I was like what the [__]
it's good
you see all those machines mister
you didn't see all those big old
machines back there huh
I scared you that's for our pool you
want to see it yeah they're building our
pool Mister yeah
yeah what happened where's the vacuum
what vacuum yes the vacuum the Roomba I
don't know
we're showing the machines first don't
get distracted oh I didn't know you were
vlogging nope this is real life hey look
Mia got that he got a haircut Mia
it was different about it well she just
looks like
she looks clean let's go outside show
them outside
yeah look look at that look they're
building a pool Isn't that cool they're
building the pool dude you're not cold
Mister you're insane
of course the big pile of dirt
look at that big hole dude
yeah so you and all your little friends
stay safe
so our action-packed day
just got more action and since Myanmar
bear are super busy all the time today
is Valentine's Day
yeah and uh you know once you have a kid
you don't really have time to really
like
spend time on a weekday and trying to
get babysitters like it's just the whole
whole thing so we decided to spend
Valentine's Day by hiring a private
sushi chef his name is Joey and he'll be
making everything for tonight so like
what do you bring to be able to set up
like a straight up like sushi restaurant
so
well I like to do within this company is
I like to bring all the fish that I get
from the market yeah I kind of portion
them into the blocks that I need and I
bring it here to you and I portion
everything out in front of you oh
watching the freshness of everything I
don't really like to bring anything like
pre-made when I do these events so
everything I get from the market I
Source it I prepare it so it's ready to
go and when I come here I just do all
the preparation in front of you and then
I serve you the great food that I have
wow so it's like every piece you make
and then we eat it correct oh that's
cool of course by chorus and then I have
a full tasting menu yeah brought a
little bit of extras too as well so um
after we do all the tastings we could do
any special requests oh very cool
whatever you guys want to try out can I
see what fish you brought yeah so I have
a
we're gonna have yellowtail belly and
salmon belly this is going to be
Scottish salmon and then I also have
some Waggy right over here wow yellow
belly and Otoro oh man okay
sounds dope yeah we have a bunch of good
stuff for you and then we're gonna make
some special rolls as well hell yeah
thank you of course so the dinner's set
to be around 5 30 ish he needs about two
hours to prep so he came right around 3
30 ish
um this is super cool I've never had
this experience ever and I figured this
is probably gonna be way better than us
getting dressed up looking for our
babysitter going to a smashed restaurant
where they have prefix menus and
everyone's slammed and everyone's like
reservations out the Wazoo we can do
this
and just regular clothes and just chill
and be super relaxed one funny thing
though even though it's Valentine's Day
and we already have a third wheel which
is like our buddy silent Mike is coming
over to visit not for Valentine's Day
but it just landed on Valentine's Day so
we decided to just add them to the
dinner so it's gonna be me and my bear
and then two other Wheels
this guy's nuts
[Music]
what
are Sushi knives like super sharp uh yes
usually Japanese still if you were to
buy a Japanese knife it will come sharp
but within um our industry it's all
about how you maintain it so some chefs
have a hard time maintaining their
knives whether it's like good quality
seal or bad quality seal but the whole
thing is if you don't know how to
sharpen your knife these expensive
knives that you're using you'll chip
away they have like uh lives oh so this
knife has like a lifespan use this for
like the next six years yeah but if I
didn't know how to sharpen it then I cut
that down to like two to three years oh
wow as as much as it is to learn about
like sushi and making sushi yeah there's
also a whole lot to learn about like the
maintenance for your knives it's very
very important how much is a knife like
that this one it's a masamoto I've got
this one for 650 damn 600 for a knife
yeah my whole connection is kind of
pricey I have a pretty pretty extensive
collection of knives that's cool though
thank you I like dope stuff
you want to see some of the stuff that's
been prepared yeah
wow it smells whoa how pretty that's
cool how the presentation is awesome
yeah look at all this fish
I know you're gonna sneak up and grab
one aren't you come here
she loves food the minute she smells
food yeah she's like zoned in
she'll eat a wrapper just because it's
flavored I still eat flavored plastic
get out of here my dog is a little
Menace too man like every time I leave
the house like yeah he's old enough and
I Kendall trained him when I first got
him so he's pretty smart and obedient
yeah I always have to like tuck my trash
like yeah yeah yeah because if I leave
and I come back he'll just get into it
and he knows better because he's a smart
dog but um yeah I know how it is
[Music]
yes are you ready bikini oh
oh it's already
this is the best ever
[Music]
best ever home
and we got this crazy third wheel oh
this guy
she's gonna be uh just the first starter
for today what I have is a truffle
bluefin tuna from Spain and right over
here underneath is gonna be a crispy
seaweed uh the sauce that I have
finished for it it's a sweet eel sauce
and a little bit of our smoked sesame
seeds
wow enjoy it yummy well I could hear a
taco in the toilet romantic
and I just do I mix it up
mix it up there's cucumbers uh here let
me guess what was this again cucumbers
this is gonna be a snow crab seaweed
salt with avocado and seasoned crunch
flakes oh wow enjoy guys thank you don't
mind if I do
[Music]
I promise you and maybe five years
should be like I love this yeah five
years when you have the salmon you'd be
like can I get 12 orders of salmon it's
funny I remember like just being in a
suitable for him so we already finished
like half the plate uh but you said
where was the yellowtail from yellowtail
is from kagoshim Japan and then the
salmon that I have for you today is
gonna be Scottish salmon it's one of the
fattiest and highest quality uh Salmons
that you could get in the market really
good there's like no fishiness to it
it's Super Fresh this has a slice in
your mouth slices serrano chili Yuzu
ponzu he said it's so good it didn't
turn on the tea light screen guys
it's like melt in your mouth
good
got some fresh real wasabi
soy sauce
we got first are you gonna eat it the
American way or the Japanese way with
the hands yeah
[Music]
it doesn't get better than that some
bomb ass food
custom-made Sushi to end the day what a
crazy day right Valentine's Day
started Excavating our pool then it
snowed out of nowhere and then ended the
day with some yummy food
thank you guys for spending Valentine's
Day with us see you guys next time